وافاد الجيش الاوكراني براسد زياده في عدد
السفن الروسيه التي وضعت في حاله تاهب
قتلي على جبهه البحر الاسود واكد استعداده
لهجمات الروسيه على نطاق النواسع من تلك
الجبهه بدورها قالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان قواتها الجويه شنت خلال
الساعات الماضيه غارات على مناطق تمركزي
القوات الروسيه
[موسيقى]
قصفت نقطتي تحكم واتساع مناطق موضع
للافراد والعتاد ومستودعا لتخيره فضلا عن
محطه اتصال اللاسلكيا للجنود الروسيه
الى انها رصدت نحو الستين غاره جويه و 69
هجوما صاروخيا شنتها روسيا على مواقع اخرى
اوكرانيه عده بما فيها البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه
في مقاطعه الدين برو جنوب اوكرانيا افادت
سلطات والمحليه بارتفاع حصيله قتل القذف
الروسي الذي استهدف بنايه سكنيه يوم امس
الى 20 قتيلا اضافه الى 73 شرحا وقالت
السلطات ان عمليات الانقاذ لا تزال مستمره
وان مصير اكثر من 40 شخصا لا يزال مجهولا
ووفقا للاداره الاقليميه في المقاطعه فانه
نتيجه للضربه الصاروخيه على المبنى السكني
تم تدميره اثنتين و 70 شقه بالكامل ولحقه
اضرارهم باكثر من 200 شقه سكنيه
في حين لا يزال رجال الانقاذ يفككونا
الهياكل هياكل المدره بعد ازالتهم حوالي
3,500 طن من الحطام الذي خلفه القصف